ازمه نقص عالميه في ابتلاء الوردي تسبب
بها في المبرر الجديد الذي سيعرض في يونيو
المقبل لكن لماذا مخرجه الفيلم الامريكي
غريتا جراوي اصرت على ان لا تستعين
بالمؤثرات البصريه في فيلمها الجديد وان
تبني ديكورات ورديه او زهريه حقيقيه في
موقع التصوير في العاصمه لندن بدءا من
منزل الاحلام الشهير الى الطرقات واعمده
الاناره ما تطلب كميات هائله من امتلاء
اللون الوردي وهذا الامر تسبب بنقص عالمي
في اطلاء الوردي وفقا لتصريحات كريتا شركه
روسكو المسؤوله عن تصنيع تلاء المستخدم في
الفيلم اكدت انه استنفذ مخزونها من الطلاء
الزهري واوضحت ان انتاج الفيلم تزامن مع
مشاكل عالميه في التوريد والتصدير خلال
فتره تفشي فيروس كورونا الى جانب الظروف
المناخيه القاسيه التي شهدتها ولايه تكساس
عام 2021 والتي اثرت بشكل كبير على
امكانيه الوصول الى المواد الحيويه
المستخدمه في صناعه الطل اء الوردي